liam to play that so it'll be really
interesting uh kind of what avenue he
chooses what opening move liam
okay he has started with one d4 and uh
if white brings out his dark square
bishop on the next move or the next two
moves we would have seen a london system
but no that's not going to happen
wow we see the king's indian defense not
something we usually see from magnus
these days uh look at this white
occupying the center with a lot of pawns
black is just going to play on his first
three ranks uh for the next well for the
foreseeable future and uh okay magnus
it's not usually his style but he did
have some success with this opening last
summer during the world cup and some
other events and okay this little pawn
push is one of the most fashionable
lines of the king's indian and magnus
just looking out the window there
looking off to the right
he's just trying to pick an opening uh
pick maybe which black pawn to push you
need to challenge white center before
it's too late before white just gets
everything gets the dream position and
there we go the center actually blocks
itself up so no trades in the middle of
the board that would only have helped
black because the white king is in the
center and white's king being in the
center isn't such an issue now that
things are blocked up in the middle and
just checking the database i can see
that
this particular pawn little pawn push
that lay made very quickly is actually
his specialty he plays it very regularly
and
going on the attack uh the white pawns
look at white's pawns in the center and
on the right side of the board all on
the light squares and uh you talked
about clamps ivanka
he now liam is trying to clamp down and
stop the black from breaking out and
this knight retreat i'm just trying to
think um actually gawain jones recently
released a chessable course on the black
side of the king's indian and i think
this position or something very similar
at least features in that chessable
course so maybe magnus has been checking
out what gawain jones one of the world's
leading experts on the king's indian has
recommended
really interesting play note how white
rook actually stepped to the side lining
itself up with a black king so white
cannot castle anymore on the right side
of the board he wouldn't have done that
anyway it's too exposed over there and
uh magnus just
kind of rerouting his knights for now
this one all pieces on the board and
they will be for a long time that's
going to be very tense definitely and
what i like about this is by magnus
choosing this particular opening it
means he's ambitious he wants that fight
having said that he has kind of walked
into
something that uh liam actually knows
really well i mean i'm looking here and
i'm seeing that there are three games
by him on the database he's the highest
rated person to have played this
particular variation so it's something
that he believes in and i love it when
players
do this because it means that us as
chess players can actually copy what
he's doing wow and harry the h pawn
marching up the board and
sorry there you go i was going to say so
far he's actually following a game that
he won against the indian grand master
harrika dronovali in 2021 so
liam has good memories of this variation
it was a blitz game though that he won
do you think magnus will be aware of
that game magnus has a great memory and
he plays through i mean he always every
time i see him even out at restaurants
he's always on the chess 24 app playing
through games from that day live games
games from all over the world so even a
blitz game he might be aware of it's
insane i can't guarantee it but it's
quite possible wow i think we'll find
out by how uh how quickly or how slowly
magnus starts to play over the next few
moves but um just to hi okay he does
play quickly so he's at least aware of
this kind this kind of pattern if not
the exact position and the idea behind
white's pawn pushers is pretty simple on
this right side of the board those white
pawns are just going to push towards the
black king maybe open up lines um at the
very least black will lose a lot of
flexibility
and black will have to maybe keep his
gaze focused on this king side once the
white pawns uh start pushing but magnus
for now undermining the white center
uh this makes a lot of sense if your
opponent has a bit more space as white
does here
if you look at the white d5 pawn
very far advanced it's just kind of
cutting the board in half then yeah you
have to undermine your opponent's
strongholds and uh okay very tense we
won't see a trade of pawns from white
side white will never capture this black
pawn that's just moved because that
would only uh remove white's strongest
point but also uh help black to break
out the trades in this position would
only favor black and there we go
consistent pushing harry even further up
the board and look at the black king
already feeling a bit shaky and uh liam
just ignoring the queen side ignoring
the center for now just playing with the
one trap knight pushing pawns towards
the black king
and uh well liam is still in familiar
territory here he hasn't been surprised
uh he's following a game this time
they've kind of moved from his game
against harika and it's now a blitz game
that he played against luis supie
brazilian grand master
and actually it's quite interesting
because in that particular game he lost
oh so you know
magnus i think is definitely steered the
game into this particular variation he's
kind of predicted what's going to happen
and i'm looking forward to seeing what
magnus has up his sleeve
yeah and this is the type of position
where white at the moment has control if
you look at all of white's pawns they
control squares they defend each other
but
your piece development is not great
white's king is still in the center it's
light-squared bishop at home where it's
rooks still far far
away from being connected so if white
loses that control if black is able to
break out with his pieces explode open
the center of the board then everything
will be in black's favor so it's very
much white trying to keep control and
we'll see that from the next five ten
moves from them black will be trying to
create chaos uh because i think um
partly magnus will like that liam is a
kind of control type of player but also
this type of position with the white
king in the center if white does just
blink for one moment and allow things to
open up
yeah the king will be stranded
so yeah i mean what an exciting start to
the game neither play player playing it
solid playing it safe and i would have
thought liam with the white pieces being
the leader of the prelims a draw would
be fine for him but he's gone really
aggressive with this opening oh we love
it and yeah remember if magnus carlsen
wins this game gaining three points they
will be tied
on points a draw for liam would mean
that he's still leading by three points
so impressive by liam to go for a real
fight in this game that's what we love
to see
he knows no fear um we often talk about
the young players being the fearless
ones making big brave decisions but liam
the reason he's at the top of the
leaderboard is because this whole
tournament he's taken risks he's shown
no respect to players like ding uh
players like rapport yeah yeah i mean
all of these guys in the field he's just
been beating most of them so
he's playing some fantastic chess as
well you know there's been quite a few
sacrifices really wild chaos as well on
the boards so i mean it's been a
pleasure to to see his him playing like
this and uh well magnus here actually
not choosing the main line and
developing the light squared bishop
instead of capturing in the center which
has traditionally been
more popular move yeah very logical
though developing a piece that can't be
anything really wrong with black's move
and again it comes down to white how is
white going to improve the pieces
i wouldn't be surprised to see maybe
white's light squared bishop just take
one square
just kind of develop itself off the back
rank the white queen could move white's
kingside knight the one on the right
side could just step back these are all
typical ideas one thing you don't want
to see uh for white and just we were
talking about control here uh one thing
liam shouldn't do now that he's thinking
is trade off pawns so
a couple of porn trades are available to
white you don't want to open things up
okay yeah you have to keep things closed
because black is cramped
he is
from vietnam but he lives in the us
and he is actually a teacher a chess
teacher right for at a university
webster university wow
a full-time job
and still being able to uh compete at
the highest level in chess super
impressive and uh liam actually playing
one of the moves that you suggested
retreating in the night and just uh
solidifying the center because as david
mentioned it's all about control now
that white has maximized the pawn side
expansion there on the right side he's
just all about okay well now let me just
reinforce the center let me live with
this extra space and just wait for black
to break out yeah and talking of
breaking out for king's indian players
at home and i know it's very popular at
the club level amateur level um this
type of position is quite typical but
black's normal pawn break is to actually
pick up the f pawn and push it forward
uh two squares black's f pawn in front
of the rook just throw that forward open
things up go for the white king but here
it's not possible because white's rock
on the on the g file is staring down at
the black king so basically that's the
problem for black it's frustrating this
type of position you can't open things
up and also it's not your typical
conventional uh king's indian ideas and
that's why i think this line is so
popular for white because black king's
indian players they they know one
pattern and they stick to it and it
brings some success but here they're not
allowed to go for their uh favorite idea
uh their favorite concept so okay
meanwhile magnus
he's just reacted to the push of white's
h-born by pushing his own a pawn forward
and uh black trying to use this pawn
that's just moved as maybe a bit of an
annoyance for white
just trying to destabilize white over
here on the left side also creating a
square for the black queen to jump out
to and dm says no no more pawn advances
uh white just blocking things up again
trying to keep control
and uh yeah liam we mentioned webster
university he actually he now occupies
the job that susan polgar used to
used to
kind of have at webster university and
he has some really strong
i say students but there are some of
them at 2600 levels so
obviously they work together and i think
that really helps his game so he might
be the teacher he might be in charge but
uh he's definitely picking up ideas from
these young university students who are
hungry really hard working are there
some up and coming that the the chess
world is sort of keeping an eye on well
this is the whole point of the the
webster university and other university
scholarship programs you know they pick
stars that they think are going to be
rising they're going to be the best ones
in the world and so what they do is they
you know they invite them to the
university and and then you have the
chess teachers training them and it's
kind of really like a hive mind there
everyone is working together studying
together they have access to
the best um
computer technology as well
like ai
yeah we're not the a i'm not necessarily
ai but you know just uh they have very
strong engines and strong processes and
things so it is really very much a kind
of a community spirit so it's like david
said it's not really surprising that
liam is doing so well and in my mind
i've idolized of everything you know
i've kind of like they get together
after the games they're like yeah oh
yeah hey coach she could have played
this and this and this hey we got this
great idea coming up
whether it happens like that i don't
know
but uh in my mind it's like a fraternity
or a sorority yeah in college and they
have these college parties and chess oh
i want to live that life
yeah i mean they've had students i mean
actually liam himself they've had ray
robson an american grandmaster they've
had ilya nizhnik um yeah peruvian's top
grand master also there so yeah
it's impressive what's going on in st
louis right now with the universities
they're recruiting all the top players
all the top young players of the world
and meanwhile just a couple of moves on
the position we did see our first pawn
trade so it took 15 16 moves but we did
see a capture in the center and i was
slightly surprised to see liam take and
with his knight and white's knight in
the middle of the board now parked in
the center being undermined by magnus so
magnus is going to try and open things
up as we mentioned it's that fight of
control magnus trying to undermine white
in the middle of the board white just
trying to lock things down and i am
slightly concerned for the white king
yeah
things to open up i just wanted to point
out that david was surprised about the
night capturing the pawn in the middle
and that is with good reason because
before white had only really captured
with the sea pawn uh so now the players
are on totally new ground
and it they're on their own and it's up
to who playing the most accurate here
because now the price of every move is
going to matter significantly if white
does a misstep then it means that the
initiative will be on black side if
black also maybe mistimes of pawn break
then the position will open up in
white's favor so incredibly sharp
position and incredibly exciting and
also i have to show you a few selfies
because i love it when everyone gets
involved in the actions and shares us
how they're watching the show and
benjamin says chess and cartoons oh
nice and uh abhishek lal says sorry
absolutely
uh says the this five-year-old
constantly complains that his dad
watches this chess show instead of
playing with him oh well play chess
while you watch you guys exactly and
then you can have names on the pieces
and you know multitasking is hard though
at the same time oh you can you can
follow the games you can go old school
this is how
i don't know whether i should say this
you know when i was a kid and i was
following
chess
a long long time ago
we would also have the board and we
would follow the moves as they happened
and we were trying to kind of as a
family try to figure out what's going to
happen yeah and uh that's a nice family
yeah it was a really nice family
activity and we also
used to do it via tally text
i also remember telling texting don't
worry that's another generation
yes
all right well this game david who would
you say is like the star players in each
camp here yeah i was going to say
white's knight in the center of the ward
was a star player but it was about to
get traded off by one of black's knights
oh look at the bar here yeah it's taking
a step back but
to me that just looks like a loss of
time and there we go blacks knights are
the ones starting to creep forward this
night now is going to jump into the d4
square there are some holes in white's
camp and okay liam really trying to
clamp down and continuing to push pawns
is still the type of position that okay
let's not pay too much attention to the
evaluation by yet but if white is
careless and it does feel like liam's
playing a bit too slowly in terms of
peace development then yeah things could
really turn against them and look at
this blacks knights of the now the star
players
yeah
yeah kyle you mentioned star pieces
people could be asking why can white
just not play bishop takes night get rid
of the problem piece after all it's
something that i advocate on a regular
basis however if you do that you get rid
of the sole defender of the dark squares
and
you give black on a plate every single
dark square there is on the board and
you unleash this bishop that is sitting
there currently looking at his own pawn
so nope that knight in the middle of the
board totally taboo
uh liam is gonna have to maneuver like
crazy and
ugh that is not the move that you want
to play either why does that
move because now white can never ever
castle on the left side of the board
either you've moved both rooks and once
you've moved rooks you lose your
castling rights
so white's king now is destined to stay
in the center forever i would have
preferred to keep the rook in the corner
just to hint later on at least that
you're going to castle even if it's uh
even if it's not safe at least magnus
will have to worry about the king kind
of running away evacuating itself but
now magnus is 100 sure the white king is
going to be fixed in the middle of the
board and therefore it's an easy target
if you know where your opponent's king
is gonna lie you can attack it
especially in the center it's uh yes it
should be quite easy and i could imagine
magnus now just throwing some pawns
forward even at the cost of pawns just
to open up lines towards this white king
uh black's king for now super safe the
formation around it is blocked and yeah
i mean this white rook especially the
one that's just moved what is it even
doing there i understand maybe it was
going to get attacked by some of black's
knights but
it's on a sad sad square my mind leaning
forward he is uh definitely liking this
the bar is saying 2.5 advantage for the
world champion and in the very critical
game for qualification between pragnanda
and niman i can see the bar is over to
the 16 year old's side
if he wins that game then he will
go into top eight for now and hans
niemann will
be outside of top eight all right
critical
i
game
took a peek over it looks good for
prague but still far far uh from a
result
i'm actually surprised by magnus's last
move i felt that uh
liam's small rook move actually
should have been a kind of a sign for
aggressive uh and
action i was expecting a pawn break or
maybe improving the queen
bart didn't like it yeah the bar didn't
like it and uh right now okay after this
rook move at least white has ideas at
least white maybe will bring the bishop
out to the side and start trading some
stuff off maybe one idea for liam will
be actually to castle but
doing it by hand as we say so
for example if blacks moves across the
white bishop might move and then the
king might just scoot over and run away
to safety this is really unconventional
definitely don't try this one at home
but it looks like liam has been given
the time possibly to get his king safe
and ivanka you said you were surprised
by black's moves you thought maybe there
was something quicker yeah it was you
know the first move that kind of sprang
to mind was actually just a break in
this in the
that's the move
this is the most typical move for a
king's indian player their dream as you
mentioned ivanka is to push this f-born
forward to open up the rook to either
dislodge the white bishop or just to
whoops sorry capture in the center with
a pawn and open up some lions and maybe
magnus missed this idea missed the at
least the one opportunity for this idea
to happen because yes white can play on
passant but at least now the queen would
come out and suddenly some danger but if
we catch up with the game black instead
brought the rook to the central square
and after white's rook lifted magnus
just playing positionally maybe he
missed a chance to go on the attack and
uh it's a stylistic thing magnus
typically is a strategist he wants to
just improve his pieces we talk about
how he likes to bring everyone to the
party he has improved his bishop he has
improved his rook but maybe he missed a
direct opportunity to just blow open the
middle of the board and go for this
white king in the center and now i think
liam has to find this idea i think if he
doesn't find it he's going to be toast i
think he needs to just bring his bishop
out somewhere and then just shuffle his
king to a safer square you definitely
don't want your king opposite a black
rook for too long because uh the
position will eventually open and the
other point your man made earlier
okay he doesn't go for this he doesn't
wow i wonder whether he's got um
very ambitious intentions that we say
optimistic maybe is a better word he's
thinking you know maybe the rook maybe
the queen can move a bit to the side the
h line and uh do something there
maybe at the right time yeah maybe you
just uh for example if i give black a
couple of moves the white queen might
slide across and then the white rook
might slide across and after a trade of
pawns you might try and uh sneak in with
the white queen and rook here but it's a
pipe dream it will never happen and even
if this does happen even if black gives
you plenty of moves this is never ever
checkmate with the bishop on this square
uh the white queen has just wasted five
or six moves so i don't think liam
is really going for checkmate what is
his idea though that is the question and
magnus just improving his other knight
i think liam again sooner or later he's
going to have to bring his king move the
bishop and just bring the king across
another idea maybe planting the knight
back in the center of the ward at some
point you do have to be careful however
of black jumping in for example with a
night check at the wrong moment because
this would be a check and maybe the
bishop could be captured so still really
really complex i think magnus missed as
ivanka mentioned that pawn push which
would have been fantastic for him and we
saw the evaluation bar shoot all the way
down because black has played a bit
slowly and to show what's happened okay
it's all about these nights and is the
liam star
player back in the game it's a white
knight back in the game but it could be
captured at some point so
it's uh it's a big question though
because if black ever does capture then
after white recaptures black's knights
are suddenly going to lose contact with
each other
there are threats and
suddenly white again has the space
advantage the nice pawns that we talked
about earlier in the game so yeah really
tense and in the current position i
still don't know whose position i prefer
and uh yeah i hope that continues
because this type of battle where it's
kind of going either way it's in the
balance still actually only one set of
pawns traded 21. this type of game is
always the most exciting yeah i i do
have to say i really like black's
position i feel that game magnus maybe
didn't choose the most ambitious option
but he's kind of gone for something very
safe you know just
just based on the kind of like visual
harmony of black's pieces they look nice
don't they the bishop is good
king definitely the pawn structure is
good the king like you say is super safe
especially the black knights and look at
wise pieces
clumsy doesn't even begin to describe it
and i mean there's no point to any of
the pieces so well how about the white
queen and
the the rook behind it i mean they are
lined up towards the black cake yeah
they're lined up towards the black king
that is true but they're looking at
their the white pawn
and you know these powerful weapons they
really do need open lines because that's
the most effective use of them if
they're just staring at their own pawn
porn is just in the way
so it's there's no kind of easy point of
attack at the minute and as david
highlighted in a few moves earlier if
the queen and rook tried to line up on
the h line then doesn't get anywhere
either so the big problem for liam is
again how to tuck his king into safety
and again just
enjoy his space that's his kind of
long-term goal
just trade off some pieces clarify the
position
keep control of the space
and wait for magnus to do something
i must admit i'm impressed by both
players calmness at least on the camera
at least visually because i would be
feeling a bit frantic a bit nervous
around here just
one side eventually is going to break
the tension we will see some peace
exchanges like we mentioned black bishop
may be taking the white knight or
something along those lines but when
that happens it will be chaos and
just the fact that both spent quite a
long time over the last few moves it
means they're both unsure of the plans
unsure of when to make that break when
to make that trade but uh yeah at least
on the camera wow
yeah mine is going up to thinking now
for three minutes what moves which moves
is he looking at
um he's looking at pawn breaks most
likely also the first thing we talk
about in every position checks captures
and threats
no good checks available for black
actually maybe one black's knight could
jump in as i highlighted and check the
white king so possibly that's on the
radar if he's not a fan of that one
he'll rule it out then he'll look for
captures for example black's bishop
taking the white knight there we go and
he does actually capture i was going to
say the next thing he looked for he
would have looked for if he wasn't
attracted to this move would have been
threats creating some threats i have a
question here can just black abandon all
idea of material and just go i'm going
to jump forward with the night just give
up which night um sorry yes the knight
that's under attack jump it forward to
the f4 square i know he doesn't go for
that jumps back where he came from a few
moves ago i like your move ivanka
jumping into this square however i think
right now it wouldn't quite work because
the bishop could take i mean it has a
choice of two nights on the menu you
should take this knight and this pawn is
actually overworked after a capture
unfortunately this knight will drop but
uh that's a nice idea because
it's very typical actually if the bishop
had taken the other knight then suddenly
this bishop is unleashed on the diagonal
this rook is unleashed towards the white
king just not unfortunately possible for
magnus so he's jumped the other way and
still very tense i still i'm
so afraid of this white king coming
under fire this knight is still
threatening to jump in with a nasty
check
if you put your bishop on the wrong
square for example going off this side
now maybe the other black knight jumps
in and look at these two together
another nasty check for the white king
but at some point this king needs to
just use another use its escape route
and run away because the attack is
brewing and in the meantime it's not
easy for white to improve the pieces i'm
expecting a move of this bishop maybe to
this square just to run and hide with
the king
all right that looks but that's going to
take a lot of time it's going to take a
lot of time and there is one open line
on the board and it's this open c line
and only black will make a attempt to
control it yeah
exactly and that's what liam is probably
thinking about right now he's weighing
up that plan of evacuating the king he's
okay there we go the bishop move i just
feel that was the most logical um the
most natural at least and uh but yeah it
does take this move and at least two
more moves to run away with the king now
so magnus has two or three moves uh to
utilize his pieces make use of the open
files ivanka mentioned maybe bringing
the black rook to the c file or jumping
around with the black knights maybe even
bring the black queen over out to the
left side of the board use her on some
diagonals uh just finds an angle of
attack somehow but at least everything
is defended for white and are the the
the two knights the black knights uh
superior to
the white bishops yeah that's actually a
really good point uh kaya because
bishops and knights we talk about them a
lot and compare them but with blocked
structures in the centre of the board if
you look at the center of the e-file and
the d-file the pawns there are blocked
they've locked everything up knights are
better than bishops
when things are closed in the center if
the center is completely open if there
are no pawns in the center bishops are
better than knights usually
um so in this position it's just because
knights are more flexible you've seen
the knights jumping around loads um you
saw magnus get rid of one of the white
knights for his bishop
and i don't think white should ever do
the same and capture black's knight in
the center of the board
with his dark squad bishop because after
a recapture of black's rook suddenly
comes to life on the central file yeah
so yeah knights over bishops here every
time wow well i'm definitely learning a
lot from you david and that you can too
obviously by following our show but you
can also get a private chess lesson with
grandmaster david howell that is uh what
we're focusing on in the
auction today as a fundraiser for unicef
all the money
coming in in the in the auction goes to
unicef and if you head to cctauction.com
you can make a bid let's check what the
current bid i think it's 300 oh wow it's
gone up to 420
dollars you're a popular man david
howell
i just hope that i can help now uh
whoever wins the bid i'm hoping to help
their chess as much as possible answer
any questions and uh yeah it's going to
be a fun session
and talking about popularity i do have
to share with you a selfie it's really
cute
it's from martinez who says their watch
that his dog their dog is watching me
watching you
it's a very very cute dog you love the
animals yeah we are big fan of animals
and if you two want to share your
selfies send us your thoughts your
questions then remember you can always
tweet us using the
chess champs and if you didn't follow us
in the air things monsters i think the
uh the cutest slash strangest animal we
had uh following the chess show was a
mini cow
it was a minute do you remember the
minute it was like
this big it was it was really a cow no
it's a footstool
no we had this you remember i remember
kaya yeah yeah
it was like a mini cow a real cow but it
was this big and it was watching chess
okay yeah we get all sorts here yeah
chess is very inclusive we include
everyone so um hey meanwhile okay big
decision for magnus carlton and the
evaluation bar really hates that move
i'm still undecided it could be it could
be a really good one long term but
temporarily it's uh double-edged black
is just trying to trade off the queens
uh black's
just shuffled the queen across one
square there's tension now between the
queens liam notice how he doesn't rush
for that decision he wants it to happen
on his terms and there we go liam
actually had pre-moved he didn't even
need to kind of put his hand back on the
mouse uh he had just assumed that black
would capture the queen and white
recaptured now with the bishop so queens
have gone it's all about maneuvering so
no direct attack on the kings
i'm partly disappointed we won't see any
checkmates uh any time soon but then
again still very tense especially the
black knights are strong
so i still think magnus has a fast share
of the chances i one thing i will
mention as well is the evaluation bar
slightly on white side earlier it was a
bit more on white side computers tend to
overestimate white's chances with this
blocked pawn structure in the center
if you notice white's d5 pawn anytime
white gets a pawn on that square
computers say white has a big advantage
or white is winning uh just because
computers love space but for humans it's
maybe less of an issue especially now
there have been some trades magnus is
not cramped with his pieces anymore wow
no and i was going to say there's only
one person who has all the long-term
prospects and the prospects of
controlling the position and i'm just
looking at the open sea line magnus
holds the power of that one in his hands
he just has to get a rook to the open
sea line and there's no way that the
white two the two white rooks will be
able to coordinate in a satisfactory way
because the dark square bishop gets in
the rooks the record sitting on g3's way
and
also let's uh talk about pawn breaks as
well i mean
when we when we have uh
if we go on to the left side of the
board there's only one pawn that can
watch forward and that's the b5 pawn can
step forward one square and suddenly
maybe it's the b line that will be under
magnus's control and uh this dark square
bishop that magnus has well he can kind
of at the right time with care he can
maneuver it around
and maximize his
i i agree with you i really don't like
white's position
yeah um it's not that i don't like
white's position actually if i had to
choose i'd probably choose white but i
don't think it is right i don't think he
has an objective advantage i'm just more
used to the white side of these
positions i hate being cramped i i just
love having this kind of stronghold in
the center you need your space yeah i
need my space in life and chess exactly
yeah everyone needs their own space but
yeah i mean it's not that i'm sure who i
would choose i think i'd be pretty happy
on both sides both sides have reason to
be positive about their position but
yeah it's very much in the balance so
yeah let's just ignore the evaluation
but unless there's a big swing either
in either direction
he's going down to three minutes on the
clock
it looks like we can have a bunch of
really interesting results in this round
13 pragnanda the bar over to his side in
that very critical game against hans
niemann david anton the bar over to his
side in that game against um
[Music]
richard report is that correct yes and
that could be super important points
um and uh gwen jones
the bar is over to his side in that game
against david navarra novara is fighting
to qualify for knockout it's looking
good for ding it's looking good for fun
forest and eric hansen the bar all the
way over to his side in that critical
game against vedic these two players are
fighting to qualify and we do have a
king move yeah king move and one that we
maybe expected white's king just
slightly
safer at least on this square but it
doesn't necessarily long term improve uh
white's chances yeah i'm just loving the
fact that so many decisive games at the
beginning of today
well it's looking that way at least the
standings are gonna have a real shake up
you can see that the the players they
know that uh
it's either win or you go home after
today for some of these players yeah and
it's also great to see
people who have been struggling play the
role of spoilers because you know we
love a plot twist and they see a trade
of pawns and now the h line has been
opened ooh yeah i'm not so sure about
that when you're vancouver i think it's
just because i've been watching so many
games of computers lately
of ai i would have maybe just pushed the
white pawn onto the h6 square just to
fix it there
for an end game maybe just trap the
black king yes white has an open file
now the h file but it's not clear what
you're going to do with it even if you
bring the other white rook at the bottom
of the board across you double up your
rooks on the h-file
the black bishop in front of the king
keeps any checks uh as just a distant
dream so
meanwhile magnus making his move with
his knights wow look at those two black
knights they are real
nuisances now in the white camp and he's
preparing that pawn push that i spoke
about you know just uh pushing the b
pawn one square
and uh he has his eyes on the sitting b2
pawn yeah and okay that was liam's idea
not to go an attack against the black
king and not to double up the white
rooks in the h file but to just re-route
his rooks to the first rank so they are
connected rooks always better when they
are connected and uh magnus
ivanka you mentioned it he's building up
and he wanted to use the c file for
black the rooks especially but white's
bishop is covering the key c8 square so
blackstroke needed to take a step down
and now it will swing across sorry that
way to the c file maybe even the b file
very patient flexible play from the
world champion and
it does feel like the momentum is
changing now in black's favor
white's had to spend three awkward moves
rerouting the rook to the first rank but
what next okay
at least he's got some indirect threats
maybe against the black knights the
black knights look super strong right
now and we do have one result now in
round 13 eric hansen
won against vedic and this is especially
very dramatic for vedic because he still
has two games to play against two of the
strongest players he still has to face
ding
and magnus carlsen today it's starting
to look hard for vidid to qualify uh
eric hanson slight chances we know ty
told us he uh if he wins all three games
today it is possible for him
okay
meanwhile what do you think of this
movie i love this move i mean i was
thinking actually when
liam moved his rook to the d-line i
thought well he has to magnus has to
take some care because some exchanges
are happening so i was really surprised
actually to see magnus quickly move the
rook to the open line because he just
made a face as well he just grimaced i
don't think he saw it at all he didn't
consider it
yeah so just just okay slightly shaking
his head there but magnus he's leaned
forward he's not happy because pieces
are coming off the board knights are
going to get traded look at magnus he's
not happy at all and he's had to step
back he's lost a lot of time now with
his knights and at the very least liam
could just trade a couple of pieces in
the center of the board
black is not losing a pawn because this
black knight that just moved is
threatening the e4 pawn
so we might just see a couple of trades
but
liam maybe just the momentum turning
against him he's found a way to stop
that and uh fight back
i think now it's anyone's game actually
i if i were liam i don't think i could
resist the tension i can't handle that
at all and i would just capture the
night it's been a nuisance for such a
long time and uh get rid of it
yeah i think there's nothing else to do
you have to just initiate some trades
the only other option for white is maybe
retreating with your knight back where
it came from but that would be a sad
move to play it looks like black is
ready to start pushing pawns on this
left side so you have to speed up the
play
you don't want to go passive don't want
to start retreating i'm talking about
speeding up liam has to speed up because
he's just under one minute yeah it's
getting dramatic for liam left 50
seconds left on the clock
he looks very chill though he does
well yeah he is a
previous um world blitz champion correct
2013 yeah on the championship super
strong in this uh fast time control okay
wow liam has just sacrificed material so
he actually temporarily is a pawn up but
he's put his rook on a square that can
be captured by black's bishop if black's
bishop goes and takes the rook though
the black king might be in serious
mortal danger we have to show this this
is really really clever um so this is
the position we were discussing we
thought okay initiate some traits get
rid of this black knight in the center
it's been a thorn in your side for too
long he did indeed capture it but after
a recapture i was assuming just bishop
takes i don't know about you ivanka yeah
now after the black knight captures the
pawn in the center of the board it's
level pawns
and roughly balanced maybe he was just
scared of the black knight maybe
threatening this pawn the black rook
coming in
to annoy the white king on the second
rank and so liam took drastic measures
and here he has indeed sacrificed his
rook temporarily and uh he actually
guards his pawn in the center of the
board but if the rook is captured then
yes white is down on material a bishop
for a rook but look at this the black
bishop the key defender of the black
king has disappeared and after for
example knight takes pawn suddenly the
white rook swings across and white wins
this is just deadly the white rook
threatening to come up here actually
with a checkmate already supported by
the bishop and yeah this one just looks
deadly how do you stop this idea of rook
check you can try to run away with a
king but it doesn't work because the
bishop initiates
cage operation cage is what i want to
say and the bishop comes to f6 and not
so sure ivanka unfortunately here black
can actually capture the bishop and go
back with his king to stop any checkmate
i think you can just be
i think you can just be materialistic
give a check and win the black rook on
the eighth rank just skewer and uh okay
wow magnus did go for this he's really
brave the world champion he did capture
the white rook in the middle of the
board and after a recapture he's jumped
in with his knight but
i think this cage idea might just be
very very strong for white why can't
white just plant his bishop here
has he done this no he's back with his
bishop back but now the king is caged
forever the rook is simply coming across
and
this looks very strong for liam but he
didn't go for this instead dropping back
with his bishop trying to make this
knight
commit but now at least very minimum the
black knight can block out this white
rook from the game and also hitting this
bishop in the process i think magnus
needs to find this move i don't know if
we can get the stockfish suggestions up
but if you don't block out this rook
simply the rook is going to come across
and checkmate you and ok he doesn't
necessarily need to find this there are
other moves in the position he can also
drop back with a check that also gives
black decent chances very natural uh but
the third move there not natural at all
i feel dropping back with the knight
because this knight will be dislodged by
a pawn so okay he does find the best
move according to the computer and uh
now suddenly i think liam missed an
opportunity uh his rook not
in the game and uh if he could leapfrog
this knight and come over it would just
end in checkmate but uh this is a big
obstacle to overcome
you can't do it you're gonna have to
retreat with your bishop to chase away
that night yeah i mean first you have to
deal with this bishop
uh you have to just move it i'm not sure
where
maybe you go back where you came from
but then suddenly the black rook can
come in and harass
okay he just moves one square keeping
everything defended but he's lost timely
and i think he may have had a winning
move actually on the last turn but
yeah just now his bishop defending this
pawn
it's all about the rooks and look at
this magnus trying to open up his rooks
on these lines and it's chaos white's
pawns pushing forward black's pawns
pushing forward
magnus could go for this pawn no he
attacks the white bishop instead let's
keep an eye on the players because
there's a threat after threat every
single move and black is ahead of
material yeah but i i i was going to say
what's going to happen after pawn taste
porn but you know it does look like rook
takes bishop is met by rick takes knight
oh beloved
rook takes
would be met by rook takes knight ivanka
yeah you were saying yeah and pawn takes
pawn is the other move you're thinking
about pawn takes here and yeah this
looks really scary pushing down and
remember white can't recapture it
because there's a pin on this line
wow chaos complete chaos despite the
fact it's an end game so is it down to
those two black pawns storming up the
board that the bar is now really liking
this for magnus i think it's these pawns
and they are stronger than white's pawns
white's pawns can be stopped by the
black rooks black's rook for example can
come across and okay he does actually
capture the bishop the safer option and
now i think magnus is going to go yep
there we go he's going to remove these
pawns
and steal anyone's game
white defending those pawns and yeah
magnus is definitely better no risk at
all for him now because simply the rook
is better than the bishop and that's the
material advantage but okay here we go
he's going after the white pawns now and
navarro was able to turn it against
dwayne jones to win that game david
nevara is in the fight to qualify for
the knockout stage three very important
points for him in round 13.
yes
wow i'm fascinated to check out the
standings after this round yeah things
have really changed uh meanwhile liam
under 30 seconds he needs to make a
decision those white pawns are they
gonna drop the pawns in the center look
good for white but they are under lock
and key and okay he's just trying to
hope that everything gets eliminated on
this left side of the board and if
everything does get eliminated
drawing possibilities maybe some drawing
chances for him but it's only black who
can win right
yeah if all of the pawns get eliminated
from the left side
i'm assuming one of white's double d
pawns gets eliminated as well
yeah the rook's just so much better than
the white bishop the white bishop purely
a defensive piece it's tempting actually
just to play um
push the pawn forward the move it to b3
and uh magnus does it you need to keep
one point alive right exactly and
it's two squares away from queenie you
know you just have to get rid of the b2
pawn which is possible it's definitely
possible uh it's gonna happen next move
black is
definitely guaranteed to go and capture
the white's v2 pawn and now black pawn
that has just pushed two squares away
from promotion liam down to 10 seconds
as well
he needs to move he needs to capture
this pawn there was nothing else to do
and uh okay magnus first captures one of
the annoying past pawns
and everything's dropping for white now
it's
not quite level material it's a white
bishop and pawn for a black rook but the
white fish from pawn
really struggling okay liam at least
trying to use pawns as distractions
and i think the black king might move
here yeah there we go this is just a
typical magnus move the black rooks are
both doing good jobs one blocking
white's pawns one protecting its own
pawns the king is the only piece in an
end game that needs to be mobilized now
um am i doing the same yeah it does the
same but uh the big problem is uh
what's next for white
i mean there's only so far you can go
forward with your uh alice the aporn and
magnus improving every single one of his
pieces
yeah
i think if the queen said pawn so
white's a porn and black people and if
they get traded off i think magnus would
love to see them as one set of rooks
disappear as well in the process the
only way liam is going to save this game
is if he keeps his rook on the board i
think his bishop alone against the rook
no chance
i think he needs to keep one active
piece on so liam doing a good job notice
how he'd avoided that rook trade
white rook is needed okay oh magnus just
allows a trade of these queen side pawns
uh i'm slightly surprised he rushed with
that decision he could have gone for any
time he could have gone for this any
time over the next 10 moves and the
evaluation bar did slightly drop i'm
very surprised at that as well because i
i do remember a long long time ago at my
very first olympiad that we had a
position similar to this and and i was
told rook and bishop against two rooks
don't uh swap off into recombine just
like you said and that's kind of stuck
with me until
until now really yeah
and magnus
just putting his rook behind white
central pawn white's bishop we should
clarify is still just a defensive piece
but white can try and build a fortress
uh just actually it's hard for black's
king to kind of come down the sixth rank
it's hard for white to get the rook uh
black to get the rooks in the game and
white's rook will just act as an
annoyance
but then again black's other rook now
finally able to join the action i'm
expecting it to come down the whole way
to the first rank and kind of sneak
behind white's king to deliver some
checks and uh come i'm just thinking
ahead to the future can white set up
some kind of fortress with um
first of all pushing the f pawn one
square forward so that it supports the
bishop and then just
putting the king on the fourth row next
to the bishop so you know have the
pieces all huddled together not
beautiful chess but maybe protective
enough that's his only chance
white has to just protect everything and
hope uh there's no breakthrough for
black and computers again they do
mis-evaluate sometimes fortress
positions they often give a big
advantage to the side who's ahead of
material but they don't understand that
yeah there's just no way to push that
advantage even further
but still this one could go on for a
while
uh magnus trying to find a way to stop
any fortress being built
even if he doesn't believe in them yeah
he doesn't believe in fortresses but
they do exist sometimes we talk about
fortresses a lot um what is
basically what is a fortress it's
normally when you're down on material
but you for example as you've mentioned
you just protect everything and there's
no way for your opponent with that extra
material to break through for example um
if i'm assuming the white king might
step forward now
there we go and if white's f pawn as
ivanka mentioned also takes one step
forward
white is protecting everything
okay there is a threat actually black
has pinned the fourth rank so black
wants to go and capture white central
pawn now and the white bishop is not
actually defending anything but yeah a
fortress it's when everything's
protected there's no way to break
through there's no winning plan
essentially
so sometimes you can even create a
fortress with a rook against a queen
um
sometimes there's just no way for the
enemy to king to break through
but uh this one does it feel like a
fortress to your anchor i think white
would love to those pawns on the fifth
rank would love to pick them up and put
them back further
down the board fortresses rarely exist
when your pawns are far forward because
they're actually more vulnerable yeah
there's just too many space too many
lines to attack them um
it doesn't quite feel like a fortress
but does feel like hard work
so
yeah hard-working chess it's unavoidable
sometimes unfortunately okay liam
meanwhile
he slightly reacted there on the camera
but that isn't again maybe a threat
there's a pin on the g file white's
bishop is basically not taking part in
the game so black was threatening to
capture the pawn in the centre of the
board so white went to attack black's
remaining pawns forcing the black king
back
now i think we'll see a check from the
white rook forcing the black king even
further back
and david anton three points a win
against richard report we're gonna wow
it's gonna be so tight on the table
after this round we're gonna have a
bunch of players on basically the same
score huge result there for david
uh he needed it and uh looked like a
crazy game as well but uh okay notice
how white has driven away the black rook
and now going forward with his king
again he needs to still hope that he can
build a fortress and it looks like he's
done well liam he's driven the black
king back and he's also cut off the
black king from re-entering the left
side of the board the white rook doing a
good job
that's normally as well another way you
create a fortress you cut off the enemy
pieces
at 20 seconds it's going to be hard to
defend this only 20 seconds definitely
hard i mean i'm not really a big fan of
what magnus has done with his king i
guess he was worried about uh
how safe his pawns were on the right
side
and uh
okay sneaky it is a sneaky idea the
whole idea is that if black were to
capture the pawn
then uh y2 would capture the f7 pawn
with his rick and lo and behold the
bishop will actually manage to take off
the black rook and this position is is
more of a fortress and
it's just a lot less
easy well it's a lot easier to hold
because there are less pawns on the
board yeah black cannot really afford to
trade pawns black needs to win pawns in
order to win this game
and uh white would love to
trade a set of pawns even at the cost of
trading rooks which otherwise he might
not want to do i was surprised i was
thinking that he would put his rooks on
the fourth row
and uh target the far advanced pawn yeah
don't look good too i guess magnus has
the luxury of just maneuvering around
forever and ever
and now okay he was attacking a pawn and
the white king just defended it
attacking the black rock in the process
yeah so magnus can just go around put
his rooks on the first rank then try the
second rank then try the third rank try
the fourth rank because white is just
basically stuck that's the one good
thing i like against playing potential
fortresses is you can just kind of look
for weaknesses in the kind of uh in the
brickwork of that fortress and uh that's
what magnus is trying to do
and okay the retreat of the rook does
allow black to go back to the fifth rank
with his rook
magnus slightly frowning there
yeah
so close to winning but still so far
from winning
it's uh chess is so frustrating
and we see liam yeah he has some big
fans out there cheering for him 1am in
vietnam we know it's very late for some
of our players as well the one sitting
in asia it's late late at night for them
but liam he is sitting in the us early
in the morning actually yeah and he's
under
10 seconds
and when you go under such uh
when you go to that time control you
leave yourself with less than 10 seconds
then this is when panic starts to set in
and you have to have this very strong
mindset to be able to cope with
these
rise in uh fluctuate well this rise in
all the pressure
and i don't really like where white has
positioned his rook brooks are not great
defenders of pawns brooks
want to be doing more active duties so
now the white king passive as well now
it's time for the black king to
re-centralize itself yeah and it feels
like white's kind of on the edge
you can't move the white rook because
the pawn will drop you can't move the
white king safely you have to move the
bishop but look at this in the corner
ugh
can you not start trying to attack one
pawn that's up for grabs which is the f2
pawn
no
you can't piece the black you can do it
with the black rook on the in
an e5
you want to slide it across to the f5
square i think the big problem with that
is white's pawn will come forward to f4
and maybe the black rook is trapped
so yeah magnus has had that opportunity
a few times
and now he is going for the f2 point as
you mentioned ivanka just with his other
rook
and okay you can gang up your two rooks
against it maybe but uh i think magnus
should just focus on improving the black
king
i don't think there's any immediate rush
and the evaluation bar has suddenly gone
up in black's favor it was kind of fixed
where it was for a while meaning that
liam hadn't made any mistakes but now
maybe an opportunity for magnus
and uh does that involve
trying to find a way through it's still
so hard no matter which porn you attack
white's rook will defend
maybe time just to bring in the king
yeah centralize the king you know
magnus now down to 15 seconds he has to
make a move yeah and make a few quick
moves but he isn't really making
progress he gives another check second
time we see in this position and he does
eventually move the king he's definitely
not going to go for a draw repeating
position three times
okay the bishop does move
and 20 seconds left for magnus cross now
the next round round 14 will start 10
minutes after the last game and this
round has finished
so that all games on this crucial final
day in the preliminaries start at the
same time
yeah and uh actually we've talked about
this so much already uh in the uh
charity cup but the 50 move rule is
going to be quite relevant here because
the last capture was almost 48.
so if we get to move 98 without any
captures
any pawn moves
then it's going to be a draw
so magnus needs to win one of the white
pawns before move 98. he's running out
of time okay there have been a poor move
though so that's resets the 50 move
completely resets and this is not good
news for liam look at that white rook
it's blocked in amongst its own pawns
and the black king is making its way
around now
oh white is almost completely frozen you
can only really move your bishop
yeah that's that is true and you don't
have a great hang on a second the bishop
can i was going to say snake itself
in one way but it can't it can't do
anything
white would love to pick up the bishop
and attack that black rook on the f5
square that black rook is on a light
square and actually uh just can't escape
the problem is there's just no way to
attack it yeah instead we're going to
see the plan that you advocated in one
of the earlier games on the tour where
the king marches the way
all the way
to the right side and starts looking at
its counterpart yeah also a magnus game
yesterday
against van forest so yesterday magnus
was actually the one trying to create
the fortress against van first and uh
today
he is the one trying to break the
fortress it's funny how chess works
sometimes uh taking on these opposite
roles and black's king is really close
it just needs two more moves the black
king is going to use the dark squares
but it's just going to go across across
and go after these white pawns
on the king side on the right side and
just wanted to point out note how the
king travels on the dark squares it's
not traveling on light squares just in
case of any tactical possibilities
yeah and liam is really running out of
time on the clock but also on the board
because the black king is only two
squares away magnus surely he can bring
the clean uh the king closer now
then liam only has one move to stop the
continued journey of this black king
i mean this black king could be winning
the game and what has happened there the
players leaning back has liam
resigned magnus thinking
no
it looks like no result yet but both
players reacted right yeah
what has happened
magnus down under 20 seconds he does
bring his king forward as expected the
king is just going to go back to the e3
square the black square and white's pawn
is about to fall and eight seconds for
liam he has to make a move
he has to make sense
what move is it i don't think there are
many moves to save this guy he made it
with one second left on the clock yeah
and uh he is just moving backwards and
forwards with his bishop he doesn't have
an active plan so now the black king
simply can take a step diagonally
backwards
white pawns are dropping look at this
all of black's pieces the both rooks and
the black king are looking at the f4
pawn and that pawn is doomed so white
abandons its defense and magnus now
still some hard work to be done
re-coordinating his pieces maybe
there'll be some annoying checks against
the black king there we go but okay he's
won a pawn it took him a long long time
took him 30 40 moves but he won a pawn
now back to square one he has to
re-route his black king maybe back where
it came from
and uh start attacking these
remaining white pawns and liam just
defending both of them with his work
what do you think about that move
because it does allow black to step
backwards with his africa and offer a
rook trade
yeah that would be i mean that would
require some serious calculation
offering a rook trade right now it might
work
probably does work but uh big decision
decision for magnus any trades that you
can consider with 10 seconds left do
require courage and good calculation
okay he goes for this rook trade this is
either winning now completely winning or
white can hold the draw with really
precise play but it feels closer to the
win because black's king that's going to
say the king is going to come across
white blocks that off
the only problem for magnus now is his
pawns are doubled yeah
double pawns rather than connected
pawns
it's not ideal
that's true but uh
somehow other it just feels like you
know black has to now mobilize the king
perhaps try to
work the king back towards the center
where all the action is happening yeah i
must i must say i just i think practical
terms i hate that decision swapping
rooks because look at this black's
remaining pouring out the pawn at the
top of the board the f7 pawn is about to
get traded off and white still has a
couple of pawns running
uh i just think magnus maybe okay three
seconds he made that move with he might
still be winning but he's made it
difficult for himself keeping the rooks
on maybe
just slightly more practical and okay
it's one pawn vessel oh look at the bar
that's the thing
oh and magnus reacts has he blundered
the wind you think he's blundered the
wind yeah he absolutely has because now
that white pawn will just run and it can
run for a long time don't run with the
point drop your bishop back attack
black's remaining pawn if the two pawns
get traded off there we go it's a simple
draw white's king coming up and rook
against bishop is a draw
magnus is he even going to try no he
doesn't try and liam escapes is king vs
king it's a draw